The A to Z of isms... Youngism.
You'll definitely have heard of
ageism but what about youngism?
Are young people
discriminated against
in the same way old people often are?
It's hard to get much stats on this
and it's not a designated subject
in sociology or economics
but look closely
and you'll see it all around us.
I've felt it and experienced it
on a personal level
and so have many of my friends.
When I started my first job
I was told by a colleague
that young people don't know
what real hard work looks like.
I was judged negatively
before I'd even done any work.
Even when I used to go to the shop
having signs that say,
"Only two schoolchildren at a time"
felt like a slap in the face.
We would never allow signs
that say that about old people.
So why is it justified
when it comes to young people?
And then there's youngism
at a societal level.
Young people are treated differently
because of their age.
They aren't given the same political
rights and opportunities as adults.
While no-one is suggesting
that babies should
be heading to the polls,
many do believe
that 16 and 17-year-olds
should have the right to vote
as they now do in Scotland.
Young people are also treated
unfairly in the workplace.
The minimum wage for young people
is lower than adults
which means young people get paid
less for doing the exact same job.
Is that fair?
Even in school, which is designed
to help and nurture young people
they still often aren't treated
with respect or taken seriously.
Young people get no real say
over their curriculum.
Schools aren't designed
to empower them,
they are given little practical
advice to prepare them for adulthood.
We can't expect someone to suddenly
become an active citizen
when they become an adult.
That process must start much earlier.
Young people are our future
but need to have the power
to change their present
if we want to create a better world.
Young people have always played a
significant role in shaping society.
From the Edelweiss Pirates,
who opposed Hitler in the 30s,
to the March for our Lives protest
against gun violence,
there is a history of young people
pushing to create change
and fight for the rights
of people across the world,
not just in their own communities.
Young people today
are growing up knowing
that climate change is going
to threaten our world.
They are likely
to never buy their own home,
and if they go to university
they are going to leave
with tens of thousands
of pounds of debt
without any guaranteed job.
It's young people who
are going to have to solve
the biggest issues we face today
all while facing these challenges.
It's no wonder
there's a huge mental health crisis.
We need to treat young people
with the respect they deserve
because if we don't
everyone loses out.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!